John Leonard where did you get the title
lonesome Rangers for your book well it
showed up in one of the essays that I
that I had written and I found that I
was spending so much time thinking about
thinkers who were somehow disenchanted
their disaffiliated or dispossessed and
wandering either their own intellectual
frontier are often some stepfather land
somewhere and I just thought want some
Rangers they think so much about so much
but have no home and it seemed resonant
any of this autobiographical a lonesome
Ranger is that you well i'm not i'm not
a sad case and that's in that sense I do
feel perhaps like many adopted New
Yorkers that I never belonged anywhere
else and you can't be you know I I was
born here in Washington DC I grew up
mostly in California when I arrived in
New York in 1967 it's finally seen that
I'd come to a place where everybody was
moving at my speed and that made me
happy because I always felt that
everybody would been slow motion most of
my life but you can't ever be said to be
home in a restful sense in a city like
New York and and I've never I've never
been able to settle in professionally
either it's while books are my first
love of review television and movies and
right social commentary and and i don't
think i would be happy doing any one of
those things that the combination the
combination keeps me of seems to me now
the normal respiration of my
intelligence and keeps me going but it's
not serene it's not restful how many
years with the New York Times is a book
reviewer I was 16 years at the New York
Times and and most of those were as a as
a reviewer under my own byline five of
them I was the editor of the sunday book
review section and that was in the
middle and I discovered that you know
the logic and newspaper careers
is that you make your reputation with
your byline and then if you advance at
the newspaper it's an editorial position
and that's a perfectly decent logic it's
just that some of us are not editors
some of us are not corporate people at
all some of us do not cannot worry about
budgets and even personnel problems and
you I I was still young enough after
five years of being an editor to say but
i'm not writing I've lost all the music
in my life all of all the bouncing of
words together that that make me happy
I've got to get out and I could what
year did you leave the new york times i
left the new york times the end of
nineteen eighty-two what year did you
join CBS 1988 shortly before the
election in between I did well I for
years written television criticism for
New York magazine it's a very friendly
place for me for a long time almost 20
years but in between major news
organizations like the new york times in
CBS i I review books for National Public
Radio fresh air every week I wrote a
column for New York Newsday when there
was a New York version of Newsday until
the Los Angeles Times cereal people
killed it I wrote a weekly column there
and I wrote essays for the literary
essays for the nation so if you pick
this book up and had to write a review
of it for the New York Times what would
you say about your own book what would
you say about your style I would say
that the style has always is now and
always has been a little too fancy a
little too in love with itself a little
too jet stream vapor trail a little too
given two to two lists that that that
bounced off the items of which bounced
off one another
a little too given to to intellectual
name-dropping with the hope that it will
that it will be a short cut to something
that I don't have to explain to a reader
these are the these are the excesses I
would hope that the kindness of such a
reviewer would be that there is music in
the pros that there is a basic
generosity toward what other people are
trying to do in the arts that there is a
genuine enthusiasm for for interesting
ideas for ambitious endeavors and that
there is a joy in in the life of the
mind who was Lester Markel yes why do
you write about Lester Markel was the
luster markel invented the sunday New
York Times as as we all now know it in
other words he invented all of those
sections the week in review the magazine
the the standalone book review section
the Travel section these this entire
empire the the New York Times is to be
divided under the publisher there was a
Sunday paper and there was a daily paper
and they were not edited by the same
people and they were largely not written
by the same people Markel ran the sunday
fiefdom and he ran it with a what the
dictatorial hand I never worked for him
he had been forced into retirement
shortly before I arrived at the at the
new york times in 1967 because anybody
who creates i'm imagining this because i
don't know but anybody who creates
something from the ground up and feels
proprietary about it
and loses power is going to be resented
by those he injured who are now who have
now taken over all the sections so by
the time I became in 1971 the editor of
the sunday book review Lester Markel who
was still a vital man and his
approaching I guess 70 at that time
maybe a little older had no place to sit
no place to visit in the sunday New York
Times he was not welcome in anybody's
office except mine because he had done
me no injury and we used to sit and I
used to listen to the war stories and
how he used to do it and all of this and
this was fine I've always enjoyed this
and you learn a lot and it snows it's it
I lose no body heat but then we got into
as I described in this book a difficult
and queasy making edge of what
scrupulous journalistically and and that
is he was writing a book he was writing
a book about his career in journalism
and what he hit and what he thought the
lessons were of that career he was
having a little difficulty finding a
publisher for that book I decided to
help out which is again ambiguous
behavior on the part of the editor in
the sunday book review that's a powerful
job but so when I'm calling publishers
to see if they'd be interested in
something it's not a an innocent call
and it can't be perceived as innocent
but I did and and we did achieve a
worthy dignified essentially nonprofit
publisher for Mark Ellis book and then I
don't know if you want me to go on with
the details of this but it's a it's a
it's a strange world but book reviewing
and when at last mark l's book was
published I had the the complicated
decision of sending it out for a review
and.and I needed somebody who would be
uncorrupted by the New York Times
uncorrupted by ether malice or
friendship who would be fair to the book
of positively and negatively and the the
person i found was been bagged icky and
who was then a professor of journalism
but between bagged icky and writing his
review for me and and the assignment of
that review he went to work for the
washington post and then Bradley at the
Washington Post had a policy that nobody
at the post could write for The Times
the time said policy that nobody at the
Times could write to the post it was
Kindergarten i said this assignment
happened before you know can't we be men
about this I'm in a bind and we went
back and forth and until I had to make a
deal that I would review the book of
Benjamin Bradley's choice for the
Washington Post if he allowed back
Dickian to review the Lester Markel book
for me and he that was yet to be
determined in the future that would be
determined and and a couple of years
later it was determined I was asked to
review Sally Quinn's memoir of her days
at CBS for the washington post and i
thought this to be outrageous and I
refused and ever since I have tried to
explain to people who seemed to think
that this is not very important or not
very rinky-dink or rinky-dink on its
level it's not a moral issue that it is
a moral issue and I don't know how to
explain it except that except that when
the people at the top have basic basic
contempt for the night for the moral
niceties or the ambiguities of who
should be reviewing books and why they
should be reviewing them then that's
going to drift all the way down it's
going to corrupt the process and we're
going to end up where we have ended up
in this country now where everything is
reviewed according to its budget that
determines the news and we don't believe
anybody and
we don't we don't believe the editorial
judgment that says this book this movie
this television program is the most
important thing this week that has been
determined by forces beyond
disinterested criticism it's been
determined by by by competing with the
other fellow it's been determined by the
amount of the advertising budget it's
been determined by who owns you in the
ultimate corporate structure and
therefore the the very signals of the
culture that we depend to sort out
60,000 new books every year all those
television programs every year how do we
make people pay attention to the ones we
care about if people cease to believe us
and they have then we become one more
blog on the internet you know one more
opinion and we could be a good opinion
it could be a bad opinion but nobody
knows because we're no longer trusted
why we're no longer trusted because
we've abused our function and we've
allowed we've allowed ourselves to buy
into it I I can say now I've been 14
years at CBS I used to be very proud of
what I did because it was unusual
because I was interested in unusual
things I'm now embarrassed by some of
the things that I do and I'm going to
stop and and that's because instead of
discovering which is what I think
criticism is is mostly about is is is
seeing and reading and experiencing as
much as you possibly can and say hey
this is good this is new this needs to
be talked about so that other people
will pay attention here's something
unusual or something valuable the border
wise be ignored instead of discovering
the new and books in the New and
television in the new I find that I'm in
a new competitive environment in which
nobody on television wants a television
critic on television because you're
going to be saying nice things about the
competition so they prefer you not say
anything at all even about them this is
true throughout television there is no
decent television criticism on
television
they don't want to give the competition
to break that's gone by the boards
nobody wants an unusual book that nobody
has ever heard of unless it's on c-span
and was it's on the weekend that's even
better with the with the whole the whole
books thing you want only the books that
are already the best selling books
because those are the books that
everybody else is reading and already
talking about I mean I'm really sad that
Oprah's no longer recommending books I
think this is a great loss for the
culture but it's kind of inevitable
we're having fewer and fewer books
talked about and and those are the ones
that have the biggest advertising
budgets and those are the ones that go
into the hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of copies and I end up as a
critic for at least on CBS sunday
morning doing nothing but going to
Hollywood movies and frankly I'm not
interested and what I had to say about
spider-man why should anybody else be
interested and I'm only reviewing
spider-man because it's the movie of the
week at everybody else's reviewing and
if I didn't review it I wouldn't be
competing with the sunday supplements
with the other magazines so I end up
revealing spider-man I end up reviewing
star wars attack of the clothes you know
I end up reviewing 8-millimeter I in end
up reviewing movies I wouldn't go to on
my own and and that is what the culture
has become it's become a competition of
loud noises that determine the
journalistic agenda the cultural
journalistic agenda about which we
opinion eyes and we are paid I've always
been paid and I've always been well paid
on because of the very jet stream style
that that I would criticize myself for
my stylistic tricks I I make some noise
and some firecrackers and some
pyrotechnics and my opinion almost
doesn't matter so long as my amusement
value stays stays high but inside
there's a there's a decay
there is a decaying that that you notice
that you say I'm not doing what I ought
to be doing and and partner that is a
function of getting old I'm 63 years old
I've been doing this a long time I've
had many many many opinions on many many
many subjects but that's not the way I
feel if say the New York Review of Books
asks me to to read all of Richard powers
and I'd read only a couple of his novels
and then right at whatever length I want
about what I found there and then I did
then I rediscover why why did this to
begin with why I cared so much about it
because here was somebody who was really
really smart and who could who not only
deserved that could sustain however
close attention was brought to his work
and this is so this is a this is what
criticism used to mean to me and and and
what I intend to go out with it meaning
to me you said you weren't going to do
this anymore when do you plan on hanging
up well we know we go back and forth and
back and forth i'm in the last year of a
contract with CBS and you know maybe
will revise the terms of what gets done
but but i don't see it that way and i'm
not really blaming them I mean this is I
have no place to go to do what it is I
want to do the environment itself has
changed around me and maybe it was a
bizarre thing for this kind of criticism
to be part of a program to begin with
when shad nor shall started CBS sunday
morning um Jeff Greenfield was it was
hired was the first one hired to do the
job that I made her God and it was
specifically to review television
television that he liked and it didn't
matter if it was on ABC or NBC or or CNN
or wherever um cna wasn't there at that
time but um and then he was succeeded by
Ron powers and then I came along and
I've been there a very long time but as
I say at some point in the competitive
the competitive thing probably at the
point that the but Fox stole a whole
bunch of affiliates from CBS along with
along with professional football CBS
certainly stopped wanting to hear me say
there was something nice to watch on on
Fox and and this is this is this kind of
consideration and this kind of
resentment in this kind of competitive
drawing in and closing off and squeezing
down it's true across the board you know
I'm hardly saying that CBS is the is the
is the single guilty party here it's
they're all they're all the same you
started out very early writing for the
National Review bill Buckley's
publication and today you write for the
nation yep could you possibly have gone
from a you know a farther way and you're
thinking well the thinking wasn't so far
you have to I grew up in California
where as a long beach california as a
and you know my mother was a was active
in the Democratic Party you know I was a
California liberal I was the president
of Long Beach Young Democrats in high
school but when I was hired by Buckley
in in 1959 uh I was a college dropout I
was working nights for United Press
writing captions for photographs with
the with a Tuesday Wednesday weekend
that for forty seven dollars and fifty
cents a week Buckley saw an article of
mine about greenwich village in a sort
of throwaway magazine no longer exists
and Buckley was hiring young writers
with style it helped that i had an Irish
name and that I've been on the Harvard
Crimson these were these were
credentials that he could see and that i
had this that i was making fun of
greenwich village
the fact of the matter is that these are
the people that Buckley hired in the in
the late 50s as the magazine was just
three or four years off the ground he
hired garry Wills who was a genuine
conservative and who was radicalized by
the civil rights movement and then
Vietnam he hired Joan Didion was
certainly gone off the reservation so
far as American foreign policy is
concerned alone social issues at home
she might still be called conservative
he hired Renata Adler he hired Harley
encroaching me he was hiring people
without regard to their politics and he
was sure that the charismatic sup his
own personality would take care of their
of their politics and and he was to me
he was offering a hundred dollars a week
to learn the magazine business from the
ground up I mean I took the stuff to the
printer and you know I did I did all
with all the little things that in a
small magazine teach you the business
and when I told him when he offered me
this job was flabbergasted um and I said
I think I have to discuss it with my
fiance and he said where is she and I
said well she's a senior at Radcliffe
and he said tell her it's the new
republic which then was a liberal and I
was sold because that was you know that
was the sense of humor if he had a sense
of humor I could certainly find out what
this was like and I had a very good time
I met whittaker chambers but I met James
Burnham on that will more Kendall I know
you know many of the doyons of the the
American right which served me very well
much later on when I went to the New
York Times it served me when Harrison
Salisbury started the op-ed page of the
times they came to me to say for the
litter right-wingers who should we get
writing to the op-ed page the new op-ed
page of the times and it served me at
the Times Book Review in finding
reviewers who weren't from the same
place people like guy davenport there
were wonderful reviewers but whose
politics were outside certainly far
outside the liberal mainstream and
Buckley remains a very good friend on
the other hand Victor nevah skis a
friend equally as old going going way
back and Victor Arce from the nation
nation and so that's you know the
politics there have always been more
more congenial but Buckley is still as
Murray Kempton the late Murray Kempton
once said that if they only one phone
call to make from jail it would be to
Bill Buckley and that's the one you
would trust to get you out of jail and I
feel that to the gift for friendship was
was extraordinary I mean he helped he
helped get me hired at the new york
times when he was sure they wouldn't
because I'd once worked for him so he
dug up an article I'd written for Victor
Navasky making fun of my working for
National Review so that the x could be
sure that I wasn't a right-wing frother
at the mouth it's just look very this
was a gift of friendship in this book
you have a bunch of articles that I
guess have been written in other places
yeah for other places New York Review of
Books New York Times Book Review Newsday
tikkun yep just 142 Kuhn and what is it
cocoon is is the is the the Jewish
intellectual answer to commentary
critique une is the left-wing commentary
to Kuhn is peace now when commentary
Isla coot and so far as Israeli politics
would be concerned the editor of Taccone
even now is is agitating on on on behalf
of Palestinian statehood not perhaps
this controversial away though as it is
at the moment but they asked me to
review Robert stones novel about
Jerusalem in which oddly enough the
concept of takuma which is a religious
Jewish Judaic religious concept figures
largely and I'd written at length about
Robert stone elsewhere so this was a
natural natural thing for them to do it
did for a while there though I
I wondered about for a while there I was
invited to every conference of American
Jewish intellectuals to think about
Israel and then and I thought well I've
come a long way for a lapsed Catholic
but you live in the New York literary
world for long enough and you become an
honorary Jewish intellectual was fine
you also had one in salon.com and I
believe don't you have a relative works
there my son is the business and
technology editor of salon we are all
hoping that it survives it was it's
certainly been a casualty of the vidcom
bust and and they certainly live hand to
mouth with a very stripped down staff
but they produce something that is to me
genuinely interesting and and they and
they passed the test of any magazine
whatever form it arrives in your head in
is that they gave us a whole bunch of
new writers that I hadn't seen before
and have come to trust and depend on and
check in on and they've they've created
a weird kind of daily newspaper magazine
and I and I'm my heart goes out to them
because they're as they've had
successive purges of the staff in order
to cut expenses everybody has had to
work harder and harder and harder and
Laura Miller who's there New York editor
but also handles though all the books
section you know now is writing most of
the book section as well as everything
else she does and I can just I can see
the frazzle but and I can hear to my
son's voice Andrew when I when I talked
to it on the other hand you may have had
this experience I only had it once in
our professional lives if we're
extremely lucky there will be a period
when we are working with colleagues
were roughly our age they have our same
interests their dedicated the same
missionary zeal for whatever it is
whatever journalistic purpose or other
purpose it is baby we're excited about
creating something new defining our own
terms seeing what happens playing with
it changing it seeing it grow seeing
people respond we tend to assume if
we're in the middle of that happy small
group of people doing something we care
about doing it as well as we think we
can we tend to assume that that will
repeat itself the rest of our lives this
is what work ought to be like after all
ought to be that satisfying that
collegial uh and then we discovered that
never again is it for some lucky reason
there was a time when I became the
editor of the book review most of the
editors were roughly my age the previous
editor had been there 27 years and we
all had changes that we thought the
magazine desperately needed to make we
were all on each other side we made
those changes we had an enormous amount
of fun we learned a lot we made mistakes
and then gradually all of these people
were hired for better jobs yeah and they
disappeared you woke up woke up one day
and said that community is gone but
there'll be other communities there
wasn't not for me for Andrew for my son
Andrew and the people at salon there may
be other jobs and there may be other
collegial experiences but right now this
one absorbs everything they've got and
they love it and he'll go down with the
ship and they may never be so lucky
again I mentioned before we start you
have a daughter Georgetown teaching yes
yes they're just two kids in the family
yes I have a stepdaughter in New York
who has been working for the Coalition
for the homeless that's for my second
she's for my second marriage but yes my
two children
amy is is the scholar of the family and
she's amazing she this was a kid who in
high school wrote all over papers on Jim
Morrison of the doors and she was a
roadie in a rock band she seemed to have
very little overarching intellectual
curiosity but she went to Barnard and
every course she took exploded in her
mind I taught at Columbia during the
four years she was at barn so that I
could see her for dinner every Monday
night when I'd go in for a seminar
course and I watched this happen you
know I watched this kid who watched
television and listened to rock and roll
become an intellectual and be adopted by
the history department at Barnard
College they loved her and they gave her
the history prize and then she went to
Wisconsin for an MA and then she went to
Berkeley for her PhD and then she came
out of Berkeley and she went around and
she was interviewed at Georgetown and
you know how difficult jobs in the
humanities are right now for a young
person and but she she had her PhD and
she had apparently a great gift for
teaching I'm not seen her teach I've
only heard about her teaching and they
hired her and she's just she's ecstatic
she's she's in the middle of a vital
University and she teaches and she reads
since she researches and she she writes
and I look at that and say somebody is
somebody's one Leonard has become
respectable now I want to talk about
your writing stuff yeah we talked about
it briefly earlier and I had to do that
I've gone to a chapter why socialism
never happened here yeah where is that
what's this from where was it originally
appeared a bad appeared in salon
or how do you say in salon was posted on
salon or whatever the terms are so it
was a was on the on the world wide web
what moved you to write this well they
asked me at this subject they asked me
to review the book I had revealed a
couple I'd reviewed a futurist and and
I'd reviewed Robert buttons putnams book
on Bowling Alone these are the kinds of
books so long was that was asking me to
review the kinds of books that nobody
else asked me to review you sort of
political political books I could review
them for the nation but the nation has
lots of people to review those kinds of
books and everybody else asked me to
review literary books um so I was I was
pleased and i was asked because I you
know I would have described myself you
know as well how to put this the the
other day or a while ago there was an
article in The New York Times about
Nadine Gordimer in South Africa and she
and she refused to describe herself as a
liberal she said no I'm a leftist I'm a
leftist and that reminded me that some
years ago on a public television
conversation Susan Sontag na deed
gordimer were talking about all kinds of
things and Susan Sontag said well the
old categories of left and right don't
mean anything anymore wouldn't you agree
Nadine and Nadine Gordimer looked at her
and smiled in the way that she has and
then she said well I don't know Susan
but I think I still agree with jean-paul
sartre socialism is the horizon of the
world and I sitting this late at night
mare with admissions okay socialism is
the horizon all the awful things that we
know about the Soviet Union all of all
the feelings that we have those of us
who would say were on the left about
socialism never having really been tried
outside of a few Scandinavian
initiatives that
to describe it as as the horizon of the
world seems so impossibly nostalgic
almost 19th century but it also
describes something which is unreachable
it describes something that is that is
Nick thickets and it's it's kind of a
twilight notion and without making fun
of it it reminds you it reminds me as
did thinking about this book that that
people a lot of the people who became
socialists and certainly a lot of the
American socialists whether people I
know best became socialists for all the
right reasons they became socialists
because they believed in social justice
and in economic justice and social and
economic justice and these are not
things to be despised no matter how the
world changes no matter how many tyrants
no matter how many paul potts no matter
how many Stalin's matter that doesn't
wipe out the the kind of politics that
would be inspired by this kind of
idealism is not much different from my
parenting when my children are young I
want the best for them I want to
organize around them I want everything
that they do in the way they proceed in
the world to be fair I want their values
to be decent I want all of these things
all of these things were incorporated in
in a political platform over a series of
years in the American Socialist Party
and then of course there were the
sectarian split ups and there were all
those things that happened to that and
and while it isn't fair to say the
social has never happened anywhere it is
certainly fair to say it never happened
here and see more Martin lips it has
been a scholar of these things and I
took a course of his out of Berkeley
when I was when I was much younger and I
thought let's try to think about it yeah
let's try to think about it and in a
place like salon I don't have to be an
associate professor of
european labor movements in order to
have an opinion on why socialism didn't
happen here you know I can read the book
and I can think about it I can think
about it on my own before I read we
would put it on the screen so people
getting threatening yes I know but but I
just want to read this this early part
in the book it says this book is
published by the new press and it says
the new press was established in 1990 is
a not-for-profit alternative to the
large commercial publishing houses
currently dominating the book publishing
industry when I hear you say you wrote
for salon.com were right for them and
then publish a new press are we talking
about somebody doesn't make a lot of
money on this stuff oh yeah no you make
you make your my you make your money
writing about television for New York
Magazine you make your money reviewing
reviewing spider-man for CBS you do not
make your money reviewing books about
socialism for salon nor do you make your
money by collecting all of those in a
book published by the new press but the
new press is run by by Andre ferny used
to run Pantheon and was given the golden
parachute at Pantheon and all the
editors left when he was asked by the
random house corporate new house
corporate before new house sold out to
the Germans to reduce by two-thirds his
his list and it was a complicated and
ambitious intellectual list and he
refused and he was out so he got
foundation money and everything to start
the kind of publishing house that does a
lot of educational materials and
everything else as well as published
studs terkel because he's Andre is
always published that's Turkle so when
Andre started that publishing house I
thought here's an honest place for me to
go I mean this is i'm not i'm not
interested in I don't need any more
money I don't want a boat you know my
children are successfully launched in
the world but I want a place where we're
are where I can bring books that they
consist of the best that I can do and
that will that will that will be
distributed distributed through Norton
to to bookstores where where readers
come in who are interested in this kind
of thing and some of these books he this
is the fourth of mine that that Andre in
the new press it published and some do
better than others the last one did
quite well because it looked like a
tabloid but it was the same essential
contents but we all nobody loses any
money and this is another whole whole
story this is you know the the fact of
the matter is that until the last decade
or maybe 15 years at a stretch
publishing in the United States book
publishing in the United States would
have would have averaged over all the
book publishing for 85 years or so would
have average maybe a four percent profit
four percent the people who went into
publishing the way the same as the
people who went into newspapers didn't
go into it to make a lot of money at
other reasons and other satisfactions in
mind but we didn't think about there was
something wrong if we didn't make ten
percent or twelve percent and now people
are being asked to go 1724 thirty
percent and the business school people
are coming in and you wonder why did it
do something else why are they going
into the book business book publishers
used to be in business to publish the
books they wanted the publishing to make
sure they didn't lose money on them to
keep the process going and you can still
publish a book and not lose money you
can publish anything you want but you
can't ever ordained a best-seller that's
more complicated and and right now
newspapers magazines book publishers
everybody's got to have the twenty
percent or twenty-four percent return on
investment to the quarterly stockholders
a dividend report and this is
newspapers were never in business to
make this kind of money so it happens
everybody gets bigger and bigger and
bigger and it's bought out and bought
out with and with leverage debt and then
people get fired because you've got too
much overhead and you're and you're
paying off your debt and you keep
raising the amount of profit that you're
supposed to make and an economy which
ought to go back to socialism you'd
think an economy ought to be for the
workers in the economy think that ought
to be one of the things that it's about
the well-being of the people who make up
your political economy and but it's not
it's not let me admit to y'all confess
to you that in order to read your book I
had I would have liked to have had you
in the room with me because I could have
asked you to define a lot of these
things but I had a dictionary next to me
to help me understand but I want I want
to put it on the screen and I want to
ask you to explain some of this because
this isn't your style yeah maybe that's
heard you on Sunday morning he sees the
same style but let's start I'd just
picked this paragraph yeah page 241 I'll
start to reading it audience can see it
on the screen the big picture is that
from the get-go our core values glowed
in the dark like The Three Mile Island
and ethos of individualism is it a
vulture shroom belton chung nao got
close of anti statism what's anti-state
ism what's a belter show belden Zhang is
is a is a cultural spirit it's a you
know you throw in the German to dazzle
the credulous but it's a great word belt
and Chong and it's always it always
means what a whole culture seems to feel
and and and then takes as its as its
definition so it's the it's the it's the
world spirit of the culture and anti
statism certainly is is in the wired and
the American
code it is it a suspicion of government
on on every level but the bigger the
bigger the government the larger the
suspicion this is gonna work well by
interrupting all the time I mean or
catching bass it and then a blank check
from God then I'll go on we sprang full
blown from John Locke's higher brow a
natural-born Hegeman hedge emoni
bourgeois money grubbers let me just
stop there that's why well that's that's
contracting a lot one of the after the
after the after the horrors of the the
English revolution John Locke and all
the other gentlemen of the of the
English enlightenment got together and
decided this kind of thing can never
happen again and we've got to we've got
to write the sort of social contract in
which property is respected and nobody
ever goes to any extreme but but
property rights were we're indispensable
so you look at English history from then
on it was a very good system for the
people who already had the money or the
land for everybody else the commons kept
getting smaller and smaller and smaller
which is why you had so much trouble in
the 19th century even after the after
the French Revolution at the at the end
of the 18th I just kind of shoved those
things into into one nomic phrase or
clause then it gets a little
complicating our viewers will see on the
screen unscathed by medieval feudalism
but then there's a long parenthetical
expression with its fixed classes of
aristocracy and for Locke tugging
peasants right so this is this is a
short parenthetical intuition semicolon
exempt from 19th century Europe
ideological paragraphing fret resides
stop there yeah just plain a little more
of this well I'm while all of us is
condensed I don't I don't see this as
obscure certainly we never had the fixed
classes
European feudalism so that that should
be perfectly clear the peasants in the
aristocracy and and you know that that
tended to lead to to violent
revolutionary insurrections we didn't
have that kind of problem we were all
essentially middle class unless there
were of course there were some slaves in
so far as the the next thing the whole
19th century ideological fratricide
there you had you know you had pitched
battles you had you had you had
political parties that resorted to too
too violent means you had you had people
taking over cities you had the Paris
Commune you had you know you had all of
all of this stuff in which people were
fighting to the death for political
programs and we had none of that we
avoided all of that hearing Lee nice day
in the United States you let me go back
to that soon on call I'm gonna read it
all the way to the end of the easier I
think exempt from 19th century Europe's
ideological power grabbing fret resides
parentheses there by virtue of early
white male suffrage lots of land waves
of immigrants to assume the lousy estas
all the native-born up early mobilized
themselves and a ragtag diversity that
undermined nascent class consciousness
while permitting the merchant
princelings to play workers of different
racial on ethnic backgrounds against
each other in a status scramble closed
Peron yes and in insulated and insulated
from revolt revolting developments
insurgencies mutinies jacker ease by the
way what's that jackery is goes back to
the French Revolution and that's a
that's the a populist revolt that that
gets out of hand they start they stop
paying attention to the leader it's
essentially a mob but it began as
something supposedly better than a mob
mutinies jack raise even mug Wamps & goo
Goo's what's a goo goo goo Goo's good
government pleased to have those in New
York by a political cities to be liberal
Republicans were called
by a political system so partial to the
status quo it's almost arteriosclerotic
I want to take all presidency at
fragmenting feudalism federalism excuse
me a bought judiciary and a two-party
incumbent protection system there's a
lot in that case yeah there's this
there's a there's a lot but let's be
fair to me if you if you stop it if you
stop it Klaus my claws but I'm not
complainin I just I just want you it's
not so it's not so obscure it is it it's
when you put them all together as
briefly in shorthand the way I do it
becomes gnarly but beyond beyond are
getting out of the out of the woods and
you have a limited amount of space to
essentially address a subject that
libraries have been written on so every
once in a while if you're me you take a
deep breath and say screw it I'm gonna
have some fun I'm going to pile all this
in it will make sense if we if we comb
it out I'm going to make sure that I put
in enough so that the people who really
know this subject know that that that I
paid attention that I'm aware of this
factor i'm aware of feudalism and i'm
aware of a of the of the role of a
partisan political activity when it when
it it is aligned with them with them
with violence and and i'm going to take
my deep breath and i'm going to rush
that through and i'm going to get to the
end of it and i'm going to hope that i
will be forgiven because it will sound
sort of neat it will sound like like a
fountain or or a bunch of balloons going
up or fireworks or or whatever you know
the real beginnings of the French
Revolution
this isn't true but I like to think it
it's true was was the hot air balloon
when they first developed the wonderful
hot air balloons the King in the
aristocracy lost control of their
management of spectacle everybody could
look up everybody could enjoy it you
suddenly had crowds who could
participate in in in the excitement of
an event and they didn't have to have a
ticket they didn't have to belong and
once you release that kind of excitement
anything can happen the barriers are
down I had the same feeling about
writing sometimes almost irrespective
what the subject is so I'm writing about
socialism and this is very serious stuff
but they're passionate disputation on
all sides on this question I'm trying to
summarize why we were different and I
just get carried away where do you write
I right at home in a little office i
have i've owned a a 13 and a half foot
wide brownstone and they on the Upper
East Side of New York third scene and a
half 13 a half feet wide 50 feet deep
it's two rooms in a bathroom on each
floor that's a little garden out back
that's thirteen and a half feet wide and
50 feet deep and there's a room in the
front that's been my office since 1971
Upper East on upper east side 78 third
78th and second Avenue and I am I've
gone through I've gone through to
behavioral revolutions the second one
yet to complete itself but a bit afraid
with that writing you know 16 years ago
I almost died
from booze and so I had to give that up
and I had good advice from John Cheever
before he died it had to give up
drinking and he said that you know
writers spend a lot of time saying let
you stop drinking and you lose access to
the unconscious and all that flow of
with all that stuff when he says it's
just none of that is true this is a
sober up says you're writing doesn't get
any worse doesn't get any better this
gets faster so broke he was right three
and a half months ago I had to have a.m.
that was 16 years ago three and a half
months ago I had to have am a lung
cancer operation and there went there
what the cigarettes so I speak to you
three and a half months after this
operation having not put into my mouth
and lungs 3176 cigarettes from a pack
and a half a day so I seem to be clean I
seem to be all right but I could never
smoke again these have effects when you
sit in your little room on a 78 street
looking at your at your at your computer
screen as it is now the effects are that
you believes choreography or writing and
I write all the time you know and I've
been I produce an amazing amount of copy
or always have i'm not at the moment
because i love it it's what i get a kick
out of this writing reading and writing
but but your habits especially your bad
habits are so deeply ingrained that that
it takes it takes a much longer recovery
process than no longer needing alcohol
the longer wanting nicotine it takes a
recovery process of the whole
your whole performance style I don't
know what to do when I look at
transitions now i don't know if i could
have written I couldn't right now write
that paragraph e but having wicked fun
with because I would have had to
sustained oh and and revised and in
order to sustain a whole series of
thoughts which which had to be
distinguished one from the other which
didn't arise naturally they were they
were not in a sequence that went in a
particular direction they all spoke to
the same subject and which had to be
made amusing or to sound musical in the
in the process and so this is a piece of
this is what I love doing but it's what
I have great deal of difficulty doing
during these recovery periods that one
has as one as as one by one one abandons
one slices it by the way did you ever
finish college no I'm a dropout of
harvard in berkeley and you said you
married twice yes married what who you
might you know I'm married to a tu su
leonard whose of who's a history teacher
at the Brearley school in New York has
been for almost a quarter of a century
it's like Exeter and over its I one
skater it's better it's a wonderful
wonderful school but I used to kid her
that she taught internal contradictions
to the daughters of the ruling class and
they now have many more scholarship
students but the daughters of the ruling
class are still around how long you been
married to her 25 years yeah why'd you
quit drinking well cirrhosis and and
also I seem to have a related sort of
attack of nerve nerve damage from the
left eye on through the
left arm or whatever my father died an
alcoholic at age 44 and it alcoholism
runs in runs and families and especially
runs an Irish families and compounded by
a career in journalism I mean it's it's
as though it's a recipe and then it's
still my fault I did the drinking and I
let you know but so they told me I had
six months to live that got my attention
I got my and what year did you quit
drinking 1986 the smoking smoking you've
had how bad an operation was it well I
always said that if the if something
showed up on the chest x-ray you know
then I had to had to take care of it and
something showed up so it was a
localized what they first described as a
spot so it's not to scare the hell out
of you and then a growth or whatever so
it was localized in the in the right
lung and it looked at it and took the
cat scan and well you don't know whether
it's at that point whether it's cancer
or not it's probably there's no point in
doing anything but going in there and
having it taken out and then finding
that it's nowhere else it's not in the
lymph nodes I mean everybody's got a
different cancer story and so they went
in and they took it out it seems to be
gone and I go back in for the checkup so
that didn't but after that you know it
doesn't matter how much I might like the
nicotine kick I had over three decades
of doing this that's no that's enough
are you going to continue to write books
that's that's really all I do medicine
let you got a major book any you want to
do no you know I gave up writing novels
a long time ago as I said in one of the
pieces in here
when I first when I really started
reviewing for the times and as her doing
books like 100 years of solitude and and
you know and Toni Morrison and Maxine
Hong Kingston all these books and Don
DeLillo and you say these people these
people really know what they want to do
with a long book I was writing I was
writing novels now I published four of
them because when I was brought up to be
a writer was to write novels that was
the definition but I had no burning
there's nothing I needed to communicate
by novel and I discovered a gift for
liking other people's know we're making
people want to read other people I want
to write a memoir like everybody else
but my memoir unlike what we've been
saying here is not about alcoholism and
nicotine addiction or whatever it's the
long march to the institution's I mean I
have worked for Buckley I've worked for
the nation I've worked for the New York
Times I work for CBS I'm you know I'm i
was i was first a television columnist
under a pseudonym for life meant the old
life magazine before it died for
people's sins I've worked for Newsweek
you know I want to I want to put all
that down and see if it makes any sense
here's the cover of the book we didn't
get to an awful lot that's in this book
although some of them some of your own
life is in here lonesome Rangers is the
title this our guest has been John
Leonard you can see on CBS Sunday
Morning doing television cousin thank
you thank you for having me